so I heard Jake Gyllenhaal was in this
movie where was he I saw the entire
movie never saw Jake Gyllenhaal I saw a
guy who creeped the [ __ ] out of me for
two hours but not Jake Gyllenhaal yeah
he's that good
Nightcrawler so night crawlers movie
starring Jake Gyllenhaal Jake Gyllenhaal
plays Lou he sounds like Abel enough but
he's not look kind of is cuz you root
for him because you understand kind of
where he's coming from in a really dark
way wish the movie kind of makes you
feel crazy Lou is like the salesman of
[ __ ] he's a survivalist everything
he says he says to optimize everything
to go from step a skip step B go
straight to step C and make step C the
best step C the step C can be Brad the
gate I could smell it I could sniff him
out I was like something off about this
guy he doesn't settle right with me I
wouldn't let him babysit a kid or
anything then he realizes he can make a
quick buck because there are people that
exists in the world I don't even know
these people exist in the world they
might they had a little police radios
and they hear about crimes and they go
there and they're the ones who film the
crime scene then they sell it to news
stations and that's how they make their
money Jake Gyllenhaal's like I can make
a quick dollar doing that and I can make
a quick couple bucks and I can get
better and better and better at it until
he starts to an illegal [ __ ] because
he's just he's losing it all though from
the beginning of the movie you can tell
you clearly already lost it dude's a
psychopath and putting out there right
now awesome acting though man Jake
Gyllenhaal in this movie I'm telling you
this is every Jake Gyllenhaal movie I've
seen lately I've been like Jake
Gyllenhaal is really good like I said in
the beginning of this video Jake
Gyllenhaal was not there he was a creep
the entire time this guy was not the
Bubble Boy he was the bubble man you can
tell him the way he talks to people he
sounds like someone who took a lot of
self-help tapes and he googled a lot
it's like how to talk to people but he
doesn't get it in his mind he doesn't
understand it he's just going through
the steps he read about dude his off man
I'm telling you it's just it's
unsettling [ __ ] you know me I like it
when movies show people who are like the
best in their fields you know and
they're really involved in it and they
explain to the audience how this
business works and you feel like you're
a part of it you feel like you're Jake
Gyllenhaal going out there and finding
these stories because you understand
where he's coming from you know when you
get it you wanted succeed you want to be
the best in your field if you're not
number one then you're nothing I think
you're like oh [ __ ] Jake Gyllenhaal's
kind of cross [ __ ] am I crazy movie
makes you question yourself I like that
and at a point you're like he's the ass
in the movie I mean bill Paxton's his
rival but bill Paxson's not actually the
[ __ ] Gyllenhaal's the [ __ ]
when Gyllenhaal's talking with people
you can tell that he's using leverage
against him Rene Russo is in the movie
she doesn't awesome job she's kind of
desperate she wants good stories
Gyllenhaal knows that and preys upon
that and uses that to optimize a
situation it's a character based movie
about a character you're interested in
it's not the most likable guy ever but
he interests you we intrigues you you
want to see where he goes you want to
see how he gets to the next step you
want to see how he optimizes everything
just weasel his way forward this movie
reminded me of The Sixth Sense you know
I don't have to see it a lot I will tell
my friends they should go see it I'll
tell you you should go see it but it's
one of those movies I don't need to see
it five times before it leaves theaters
however when I look back on the movies
of 2014 I'm going to think of
Nightcrawler for sure I like you think
of the movies in 1999 you think of The
Sixth Sense guys Nightcrawler was well
acted it was interesting situationally
speaking it was interesting with the
character it was interesting it opens
your eyes to the seedy underworld of the
nine o'clock news even when things
weren't happening in the movie it was
still intense Nightcrawler is one of my
favorite movies of the year
honest-to-god Nightcrawler is awesome
tacular
so Nightcrawler have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more